tout a commencé par un simple câble
André Chagnon on avait compris le secret
et la portée suite électricien de
Montréal choisit en 1966 d'orienter son
entreprise vers la table au distribution
c'est la naissance d'un empire d'abord
un planté dans un seul quartier de
Montréal vidéo troncable des dizaines de
milliers de foyers québécois et fait
l'acquisition d'autres entreprises grâce
à la Caisse de dépôt et placement du
Québec qui en finance la majeure partie
la présence de la caisse de dépôts à
cause de sa crédibilité d'un secteur
financier sur la qualité de ses
placements et le fait d'avoir investi
dans vidéo 379 ça nous apportait
automatiquement la crédibilité en 1986
coup d'éclats Vidéotron fait
l’acquisition de télémétropoles la
première chaîne de télévision privée au
Québec puis André Chagnon c'est de les
rennes de l'entreprise à son fils Claude
sous sa gouverne le conglomérat est
vendu à québéco deux ans plus tard André
femme Lucie décide d'investir une bonne
partie de ce gain dans le secteur
philanthropique pour soutenir la santé
l'éducation et la réduction de la
pauvreté
en santé réduction de décoration
scolaire permettent à des gens d'avoir
de meilleurs emplois de meilleurs
revenus des gens plus en santé moins de
pauvreté et des soins qui se prennent en
main la Fondation Chagnon voit le jour
en 2000 et son combat n'a jamais fléchi
en 2015 l'Assemblée nationale du Québec
a notamment décerné à sa femme et lui
une médaille d'honneur pour leur
parcours de vie sa patient
pour pour l'être humain c'est sûr que je
retiens de lui il a utilisé tous les
moyens particuliers et les moyens
financiers pour venir en aide aux gens
sur Twitter le premier ministre du
Québec François Legault parle d'un homme
brillants et visionnaire en fondant
l'entreprise de tableau distribution
Vidéotron monsieur Chagnon à façonné le
Québec d'aujourd'hui et critique Pierre
Karl pilado parle d'un homme pour lequel
son père avait une grande estime qui a
su reconnaître l'importance du secteur
des télécommunications pour le bénéfice
des Québécois André Chagnon a toujours
su préserver la philosophie et l'éthique
qui ont fait son succès tant dans ses
orientations sociales que dans ces
entreprises
ici Daniel Kadjo Radio-Canada Montréal